write a binomial to express the
difference between the area of a
rectangle with length p and width 2r and
the area of a circle with diameter 4r
and they tell us that p is greater than
7r so let's first think about the area
of a rectangle with a length p and width
2r
so this is our rectangle right here
it has a length of p
and it has a width of 2r so what is
what's its area well it's just going to
be the length times the width so the
area here
the area here is going to be p
maybe i should say 2rp
2rp this is the length times the width
or the width times the length so area is
equal to 2rp for the rectangle
now we also we want to find the
difference between this area and the
area of a circle the area of a circle
with diameter 4r so what's the area of
this circle going to be so let me draw
our circle over here
so our circle looks like that its
diameter
its diameter is 4 r how do we figure out
the area of a circle area
area is equal to
pi
r squared for a circle where r is the
radius they gave us the diameter the
radius is half of that so the radius
here is going to be half this distance
or 2r so the area of our circle is going
to be pi times 2 r
the whole thing squared this is the
radius right there so we're squaring the
entire radius so this is going to be
equal to pi
times 4 times r squared i'm just
squaring each of these terms or if we
were to change the order the area of the
circle
area of the circle is equal to
pi
r squared and then we want to find the
difference so before to find the
difference it's helpful just so we don't
end up with a negative number to figure
out which of these two is larger so
they're telling us that p is greater
than that p is greater than 7r so let's
think about this
if p is greater than 7r then 2
let me write it this way
we know that p is greater than 7 r so if
we were to multiply both sides of this
equation by 2r and 2r is positive we're
dealing with positive distances positive
lengths so if we multiply both sides of
this equation by 2r it shouldn't change
the equation
so multiply that by 2r and then multiply
this
by 2r and then our equation becomes 2
rp
is greater than
14 is greater than 14
sorry not pi 14 r squared now why is
this interesting actually why did i even
multiply this by 2r well that's so that
this becomes the same as the area of the
rectangle so this is the area of the
rectangle
area of
the rectangle
and what's 14r squared well 4 times pi 4
times pi is going to get us something
less than 14. this is less than 14. so
this is
4 pi
4 pi is less than
14. 14 is 4 times 3 and 2
let me get make sure no
14 is less
let me put it this way 4 times 3.5 is
equal to 14 right so 4 times pi which is
less than 3.5 is going to be less than
14. so we know that this over here is
larger than this quantity over here it's
larger than 4 pi
r squared and so we know that the air
this rectangle has a larger area than
the circle so we can just subtract the
circle's area from the rectangles area
to find the difference so the difference
is going to be the area of the rectangle
which we already figured out is 2rp
2rp and we're going to subtract from
that the area of the circle
the area of the circle is 4
pi
4 pi
r
squared so hopefully
that made sense and one point i want to
clarify i gave the equation i gave the
equation of a circle the area of a
circle to be pi r squared and then we
said that the radius is actually 2r in
this case so i substituted 2r for r
hopefully that doesn't confuse you this
r is the general term for any radius
they later told us that the actual
radius is 2 times some letter r so i
substitute that into the formula anyway
hopefully you found that
useful